vous avez probablement vu ces panneaux
qui annoncent une surveillance de la
vitesse sur certaines artères de
Montréal ce sont des radars mobiles qui
peuvent générer automatiquement des
contraventions en cas d'excès de vitesse
tous les revenus vont dans un fond
provincial pour la sécurité routière
cette tronçon ont été retenues en 2016
pour une surveillance aléatoire certains
sont très lucratifs sur Notre-Dame et
Sherbrooke par exemple 4 millions de
dollars de contravention ont été émis
l'année dernière mais sur une artère
censé être surveillée aucune amende n'a
jamais été émise assurément la vitesse
c'est un élément de danger pour les
piétons pour les usagers qui sont à vélo
à mobylette en transport actif il dirige
l'une des trois écoles primaires qui
bordent le tronçon Christophe Colomb
entre Rosemont et Crémazie 3 km sur
lesquels des dépassements de vitesse
sont pourtant souvent observés mais
héros
c'est bizarre c'est c'est assez bizarre
alors c'est un tracé c'est ils n'ont pas
d'une route de très vachalandée dans un
courriel le SPVM explique que les
opérations de radar mobile ont été
temporairement suspendus en 2021 sur le
tronçon Christophe Colomb en raison de
la modification de la vitesse de 50 km/h
à 40 km/h et que l'entente que Montréal
a signé avec le ministère des Transports
pour ses radars concernent des tronçons
routiers dont la vitesse est d'au moins
50 km/h pourtant le document ne
mentionne aucun seuil de vitesse pour
les artères à surveiller justement il
faut vérifier que ça que quand on baisse
la luminosité à ce qui se passe et si on
peut effectivement des mesures de ce
type là vont augmenter l'adhésion des
conducteurs par rapport à la nouvelle
limite de vitesse ce constat la
directrice d'une autre école sur le
tronçon n'a pas de mal à le faire je
suis étonné de voir ou de savoir qu'il y
a pas il y a aucune amende qui a été
donnée puisque là les c'est comme il y a
pas de radar ici les les véhicules à
roulent à une vitesse je pense pas que
ça ça respecte la vitesse maximale ni le
MTQ et la ville qui ont signé l'entente
ni le SPVM qui exploite les radars ni la
Sûreté du Québec qui enregistre les
infractions ni le ministère de la
Justice qui émet les contratsions n'ont
été en mesure d'expliquer ce radar
fantôme ici Mathieu Prost Radio-Canada
Montréal